so we're we're filming this and the
thing is this is an interesting Q&A
because we kind of we can't really get
into too many specifics I don't think
too many spoilers because I think a lot
of people will watch this who have not
seen the movie yet so others like studio
executives haven't seen the movie yet
yeah listen I think guys it's like you
know everybody's kind of familiar with
the you know Groundhog Day somatic
approach so I don't know that it's I
think what you know without without
providing spoilers it's it's kind of a
it vacillates between him get his head
cut off and him having this kind of deep
relationship with his son so it's kind
of a it's a bit of a of a groundhog
tonight just for one second because the
the little boy who played my son in the
movie is is my son in real life and
that's my son really it's his first
movie and here's a little bit of movie
trivia carnahan here said we want your
son to play your son I'm like nope not
happening and we sent him through the
audition process and we sent him to an
acting coach and I was like he's
definitely gonna lose out here and there
he is
and that was Ryo Grillo so there's the
next Harrison Ford right there
so let's just jump backwards and talk
about where I mean it's a little generic
but where did the idea come from what
what how did this thing come together
there's a - really talented
twin brothers named Chris and Eddie
boring who wrote a screenplay called
continue that I read and I kind of fell
in love with and I I saw kind of themes
in it that I liked it themes about I
think this my own son of my kids and in
this idea of being an absentee father
and these things that not that I am
because my adult children are over there
and they were the cheering the loudest
so that's either a good sign or a bad
sign but they wrote a really interesting
screenplay and and and I kind of took it
and put my little shows on it for lack
of a better word and and they and
literally wrote it kind of for Frank and
I remember him I gave it to him and I
think you're you you wanted like under
some set of stairs in New York City
reading the script and he read it once
sending any callbacks dude if we can do
this I mean and this was we shot screen
tests eight years ago for this movie for
Sony for yeah for Sony no Fox Fox eight
years ago and then Joe and I had done a
movie to get then we started a company
together we did the gray and then we
started a company together
and then we were like let's go get it
was called continued at the time we said
let's go get that movie I turn around
which is yeah studio and that was the
nightmare that began this yeah and it
was a nightmare
it was a nightmare I think that and I
could be wrong about this but I think
the thing that's gonna shock people more
than anything is reveal how many
shooting days you had to pull this off
that was shot in 27 days well I was
originally forty point more you know
it's 43 23 but they cut because and
again a lot of you I'm sure filmmakers
out here and and again I'd like to tell
you guys it's gonna get easier and
you're not gonna deal with [ __ ] and
liars thieves but the fact that matter
is I'd be lying in an [ __ ] if I told
you anything else we we just wand up in
a situation where you know so people
want to make some money and and they use
this as a way to kind of make the film
make the money and listen all this I'm
saying this is kind of anecdotally it
doesn't matter because I made that film
and I'm hugely proud of that film and
whatever happened happened and but it
was you know we got we got our days we
got 15 days cut out of the budget
because while we were in Atlanta and we
had hired 300 people to work on the film
with us you know and and while we were
there prepping the film we had a phone
call from our financier said whoa the
movies not 43 days anymore it's 27 so
you can either tell everyone they're
fired and you can send them home these
are people who work for a
or you can figure out 27 days so him and
I went we were living together in a
house and we just kind of which will
never do it which I'll never do again
and for 48 hours with about 48 bottles
of wine we've figured out how to shoot a
43 day movie in 27 days and we saved 300
shot and by the way there's another
doesn't there's another general in this
audience that deserves a big round of
applause but without Scott Putnam
where's our areas right there that man
is is a saint
literally brilliant man and bailed us
out and really helped us out and and
it's our compadre and we may hopefully
we never make a film without him again
but uh it was yeah it was it was you
know I could [ __ ] and moan all all
night as he could but listen it is what
it is I'm deeply proud of the film as he
is and so that's the way it is and this
is just the stuff you're gonna encounter
guys and and you've got a overcoming I I
truly in I've seen a lot of movies I
don't think I've ever seen a movie with
this much action shot in 27 days like
how the f did you actually pull it off
well I have to say one thing and by the
way this guy's amazing
and a little piece of me dies to say
that because he's also my best friend
and partner and it kills me that he's
amazing but I don't know how he did it
and I'll tell you one better Mel Gibson
who made Braveheart and you know little
movies like that is fascinated by Joe
Carr and he's become a pal and will go
about to do another movie with him and
every time we see him his question to
Joe is so tell me how you made that
movie in 27 days so I don't even know
that he knows how he did it but but you
know but by the graces of God he put he
pulled it off you what you know and it
really was him he was the captain and we
just kind of you know fell lockstep into
what he was doing Scott you know yeah I
could say this hand on heart I never
want to [ __ ] do that again it was it
was it was the most painful experience
it was listen it was one of those things
where you know you just look at yourself
in the mirror and you go okay okay what
are you about today and and you have to
figure these things out the brilliant
thing about it was I think they're very
liberating thing about it was
I didn't have time to say let's do take
five or take six I had to figure out it
shot and if you notice there's a lot of
you know the whole thing where he pulls
his tooth out that's one shot so I went
to school on the you know David Lean
Steven Spielberg you know okay how am I
gonna pull this off and so that was
which I think listen at the end of the
day is is ultimately the best kind of
filmmaking because it really it focuses
you and it makes you make kind of harsh
decisions about the creative aspect of
stuff but can't be egregious we know
your your process your process yeah it
doesn't exist so that was and that was I
think I guess very freeing you know is
to not have to I didn't have the time we
just had to figure it out in the moment
and and so you start to see these say
Ted Williams could see the the the seems
on a curveball and that's how I felt for
27 days I never want to do that again
ever but I'm glad I did well the thing
that you have is you have a you're
repeating a lot of the same moments so
talk a little bit about trying to
balance where the f your head is in each
scene and try and talk about like for
example let's talk about the opening
you're in the condo the apartment if you
will how how many how many days did you
get to shoot that scene and keeping
track of everything you know three days
and there's a lot believe it or not
that's not the same scene over and over
again that's a different scene over and
over again it was it was nuanced and me
knew there's a there's a there's a it
was a lot of physical stuff too so there
there was no like third take it was like
and he knew that I knew what I was I was
prepared and so and I was physically
prepared and I there wasn't anything
about Roy that I wasn't that we couldn't
just on a nickel do something else
because we were that we were we were
overly prepared and that's yeah and by
the way Frank is like half his size as
he was the film I think he was like dead
lifting like 660 pounds or some crazy
like so he was but but it's also like
that whole shot where he goes and sits
down as his apartments being that was a
motion control rig
steal we lied to them and said we need
it for something else we need it for the
helicopter coming through the thing and
we and we lied to them so we could shoot
those scenes they were not boarded we
just didn't have the time to do we knew
if we if we told them if we put it on
the schedule that they would say no so
we just lied and stole those shots and
and and that's what you had to do but it
began it was it was I think it was a
level of preparation being surrounded by
guys like like again like like Scott and
people that really kind of rapport the
process that that knew we were up to and
supported I don't want to get into
specifics again because I want to avoid
spoilers but there is some real
hand-to-hand combat that you have to do
in the third act involving gunfire
stairs how again how did you guys pull
this off with the time frame well I'll
tell you there wasn't a lot of time for
preparation and any of that stuff you
know we didn't know we had the guys
until the very end because we were
underfunded like it was a constant
battle just to keep me Scott can tell
you just to keep the movie afloat week
by week we and we were along with Scott
we were boots on the ground producers we
were making the movie the three of us so
there was nobody else so along with with
being the director and the writer and
the actor in the film we had to produce
the movie with Scott by the way there
were 26 other producer credits but there
were three guys right actually making
alright so I you know it's it's kind of
a testament to kind of being physically
prepared as well you know that whole
sword fight with Michelle Yeoh what did
we do that I think you learned that in
like in like I think I think he learned
that sword fight in two hours yeah it
was like two hours and then guess who's
here who's one of our editors right
there who cut that scene yeah god bless
her it's a brilliant scene I think she
took he learned in two hours it took her
two weeks to cut that scene so you know
it's uh that's how it works you guys had
a great supporting cast and you shot it
in Atlanta I believe yeah correct so how
did you pull this all together in terms
of the schedule the budget you
getting mil getting all the other names
I mean you know listen
Will Sasso I'd been a fan of for a long
time and I was thought funny guys can be
also very menacing guys and he just has
he's a brilliant kind of improv the
Tauri guy and I thought he'd be a good
kind of foil for you know for Mel let's
talk about Mel for a moment like there
wasn't a he did not take like he took it
so by the way he dislocated Frank's jaw
during that fight scene yeah
little who doesn't know how to fight Mel
Gibson yeah we had that fight I said hey
Mel gonna do this thing I said you're
gonna you're gonna come across me in the
gym he's gonna hop by four arms and he's
like oh well I don't know I got wait a
minute you're brave for what do you mean
you don't know you're Mel Gibson he goes
no I'm not fighting now neither and I go
mal just don't cuz I'm gonna come in so
you gotta make sure that you pull the
first take he elbowed me so hard in the
jaw that this and for three days you
know there's a woman who comes and she
sticks her fingers in your mouth and she
jabs her finger in your jaw so that you
can speak and that's what I did for
three days and Mel would come over and
you know we were like don't upset Mel
don't have said Mel and Mel will go you
okay I'm all fine fights fine I'm
drinking I'm eating through a straw but
it's gonna be fine now it's good ya know
but we had you know Selena lo was
fantastic as Guan Yin I mean she's you
know there's like we really had some
extraordinary Naomi Watts Naomi Watts we
yeah we had some really wonderful people
it's great I'll tell you what attracts
actors scripts write scripts and
directors and and at the end of the day
you know his body work speaks for itself
and if you see the actors that he's
attracted in all his films and all great
actors you know Liam did Liam Neeson's
of the world and it goes on and on and
on it's the script attracts the actors
and and he wrote a great script he was
directing it and you know it wasn't
really difficult
to get them it really wasn't and they
were gone they were gone home they loved
the idea of what this was so that was
that was the one easy thing is that all
the actors were in I'm always
fascinating about the editing process
because that's the you know final
rewrite I would imagine you did not have
a lot of deleted scenes no I think we
had there's one there's two scenes
they're both mell but there's a scene
with Naomi that we deleted it was about
a guy spent three and a half minutes
scene where she's in his office there
and we as much as we love the scene
we're like it just it's not it's we need
to kind of keep the movie going because
we know why you guys to sit you know and
and and we just wanted to it was all its
propulsion based action films are very
much propulsion based and you got to
kind of keep everybody you know engaged
so no there's when you have 27 days no
there's no deleted scenes you you talk
and again I'm this is so tricky trying
to avoid spoilers but you in the film
there it is explained how Frank is able
to have these things happening to him
how much were you talking thinking about
you know the full explanation of that
and getting into the nitty-gritty and
how much is it sort of like you know
towing that balance of explaining listen
you know my movies have been like you
know narc and smokin aces in the grey I
don't know [ __ ] about sci-fi you know I
don't and and the stuff that I respond
to him that like I guess in the sci-fi
front like I love what Ryan did with
looper because it was kind of I just got
it you know there was something grounded
about it so you believe you you yeah
listen you if you're gonna buy into it
you just have to suspend this yeah
listen if you show up and and you're
gonna [ __ ] and moan about us doing like
Groundhog Day
you should probably [ __ ] off and leave
because it's probably not the movie for
you you know what I mean so if I have to
sit here and become Isaac Asimov you're
gonna be disappointed you know it just
doesn't you know so I think it was more
of simply
here's what we're doing this guy's I
think what I what the conceit that I
liked was you're not like these unlike
these other kind of repetitive kind of
time loop movies he's not discovering it
you kind of meet him and he's kind of
bored by the whole thing because it's
been happening to him so much I like
that aspect of it this kind of oh [ __ ]
he's he's he's kind of a bomb doesn't
really know what to do and he just goes
and gets drunk until he gets killed you
know and by the way that'd be me you
know that's kind of me so I think it was
more about that and then kind of weaving
in this idea that you could take his
blood and hair and kind of make his DNA
the kind of the mass in this missing but
it's funny we I gotta tell a story we in
a moment Frank and I were gonna do this
movie it was a big Chinese company and
they said yeah you guys are calling a
Collider it's not a Collider and I go no
I know it's a time machine
yeah so let's call it time machine yeah
but they wouldn't do that they wouldn't
say time machine they would say
something else you go yes time machine
yeah so okay we wound up getting this
big argument but it's this weird kind of
stasis where they don't want to say call
the time machines I said okay what if we
call a quantum displacement engine they
go that's great
he made that up I just made it up just
[ __ ] made love yeah so by the way
it's like the Stephen King thing all
that shit's made up you just make stuff
up I got a I got a stop and say that I
really wish it was called the collider
yeah I know
there you go I know there you go for
selfish reasons right exactly
see you're getting ready which which
ended up being the biggest pain in the
ass to film and why in the film which
one it being what was the biggest pain
yeah the thing that you were like we're
never getting through this oh this is
just the people we had to make the film
with no it's true
no no because these guys were brilliant
it's an every week and on a movie you
make an independent film and every week
on Friday they fund you right it's not
like they give you the 25
in dollars in an accountant may go make
your movie every week they fund you and
say they're supposed to give you a
million dollars a week to pay everyone
and to prepare and and we would get four
hundred thousand no he'd go oh what do
we do and then and Scott can attest this
at least four times we had a call the
crew together and say well there's not
quite enough to pay everybody but if you
could wait till Monday or Tuesday it
would be awesome you know if you're in
it with us great if not we get that too
if anybody wants to walk we understand
well we'll pay you no one left not one
person left right Scott did that anyway
no one left because every week we sat
with them we said hey hey jerk-offs
aren't paying us again this is what we
had to do and you know we had full
transparency and everybody was treated
with respect
again we learned a valuable lesson and
it's like if you want it if you it's
about making the people feel good about
what they're doing and that's what you
know that was the biggest hurdle making
the movie everything I know they were
seeing dailies they knew it wasn't you
know they knew it was working was funny
like it wasn't I think they didn't feel
they were giving their time to this kind
of empty you know venture that was
[ __ ] no see I think they thought
okay you know and and I think again
Frank and I being on the front line
because the other people that were
quote-unquote producers in this film
never showed up they showed up for about
two hours take a picture of Mel Gibson
on instagram and then they disappeared
which is true you know and it's like but
again this is just the reality of making
movies guys you're gonna deal with these
people like they they have access to
money and so part of us and by the way
frosty let us come out here and show
this movie to you is in an effort to
avoid winding up on on streaming that
it's just a movie that just kind of
disappeared because it didn't have the
support it needed to play theatrically
and that's simply not the case
so we are in this position because of
these I'm not gonna calm the farias
let's say Niro do wells that that did
what they did
I'm not gonna [ __ ] him moan about a now
Norris Frank we made this movie we're
seeding Lee proud of this film but this
is where we're at and this is
kind of what you deal with and to work
outside the studio system because this
movie doesn't get made in the studio
listen any more than smoke and Asus gets
made there's no [ __ ] way they green
like that film in this day and age it's
just not gonna happen so you have to
understand that and you have to either
adapt to that and do we did or not make
films and I choose to make films was
there that seemed bitter was that I just
as I as I stopped talking he is now also
in therapy so it's getting better and
better a little bitter
was there anything how did this story or
script change so you go from 43 days or
27 is it one of these things where
you're like okay we just have to figure
out how to film this script in 27 days
Brad Pitt was playing my role so we just
had got an 80 yeah no no I'll give you
examples so we had at the end we called
the jam room sky remember this it was a
Jamiroquai we were gonna do a fight
scene and use the old Jamiroquai video
where everything moves except you know
all this you know and have this big
fight between Roy and all the assassins
and we're like and they came back it's
like it's it's five days to shoot that
and so they go you got to figure
something else out and it was literally
like oh there's uh there's a machine gun
of the helicopter I'm just gonna have a
shoot everybody and that's literally how
it went down and it worked you know it's
like if you don't now you guys know and
you could be [ __ ] about and go well
they didn't shoot the fight see but if
you don't know it's there it's it's you
don't miss it you know I think I think
that Tim Miller on Deadpool had his
budget cut a little bit and that's why
Deadpool at the end of the movie forgets
why he forgot all the guns because they
didn't have the budget for it something
like that is that true yeah they do now
but it's true and I mean people come up
with stuff when you know when your back
is against the wall and a lot of times
it's better it gets better soon it's
it's so we used in the movie that it's
the it's the indie fighting the
swordsman you know it's like okay you
had this
Harrison Ford had you know it's like you
hear all these stories and and I
remember talking to air support he's
like yeah I was sick I didn't want to I
just took out the gun every laugh as
soon as that happens like oh there goes
a fight so these things are necessary
sometimes you you have to be kind you
have to have your back to the wall to
figure out what you can really do and I
encourage all of you they're filmmakers
you're gonna you're gonna get put in
this corner whether you want to or not
you're gonna get put in this corner and
you're gonna have to you have to fight
your way out or think your way out or a
combination the two as a New England
Patriots fan I know I'm gonna get some
booze
oh no they're great it's cool to see
Gronk as the people don't realize it's
Gronk who is doing the machine gun on
the helicopter so talk a little bit of a
former tight end of the New England
Patriots he's kind of good just throwing
this hall-of-famer yeah he's
unbelievable um how did Gronk end up in
this movie because I believe when you
guys were filming I saw video of you
training him how did yeah I never had a
Instagram post have more likes or repost
than the Gronk shooting that weapon
which was a terrifying the fact that
that was shooting blanks but that was
actually a working weapon I think they
were it was six bucks a bullet so that
gasp is yeah absolutely that's how I
felt so he and this is a guy who's you
know six six six seven or whatever was
and he had to literally like hold
himself in place and let and let this
thing go and it's like so it was he was
like by the way and we and I was I just
I loved the idea of a big football fan
so I love the idea of Gronkowski me in
the film and Sherri Thomas who's one of
the casting is the biggest Patriots fan
of the planet so when he showed up they
didn't tell her he was coming and she
lost her mind like they film that she
lost her mind with Ron Kowski show but
he was also one of the loveliest like
sweetest guys big kid he's a big kid
yeah and and and he's really good he was
like he's perfect for that and then the
other guys that the German twins were
Rashad Evans and Rampage Jackson who
were both former and they fought each
other in the UFC they were both world
champions and rampages in the a team for
me and a dear friend and I adore him and
and those guys were enemies and we
thought you know they should they should
play they should play brothers yeah
the German twins and Michelle Yeoh the
great Michelle Yeoh who's a legend yeah
there's some great let me show you over
one day one day you did it and by the
way that scene where she's training
Frank that was a one walled set that was
it
I had one wall to shoot that oh yeah
that's okay your applause are
appreciated encourage it there you go
let that become infectious I appreciate
that so the most takes you did in the
movie was six and what scene I think
maybe you chopping mr. good-morning up
yeah because it was a very intricate but
that was it like that was it you just
didn't have the you didn't have the you
just couldn't have the bandwidth so I
would imagine there's a lot of people
who are gonna watch this or hear about
the screening that are gonna want to see
the movie is is there a plan for a
trailer being released is there a plan
yeah yeah this movies been sold
internationally so all over the world in
all the territories where people see
movies this movies already been sold and
they all can released a movie actually
when they want to and there's an
international poster and there's an
international trailer the one thing
that's holding us up is our domestic
distribution and we're in the process
like right now of still kind of securing
that and making sure that we get the
proper release otherwise as joe said you
know like many movies today they wound
up on the streaming services and that's
great if you know joe and i have made
two movies for netflix and it's great if
you make the movie for the streaming
service but you don't want your film
which is the theatrical film to end up
on a streaming service and have no
domestic distribution so that's kind of
where we are right now and that's listen
that is the
the challenge of being making
independent movies
it really isn't it's bigger the movie
looks at times it's an independent film
it's a it's a small independent film and
you know finding domestic distribution
is there's a lot of movies that you hear
about that go to the Venice Film
Festival in Toronto and Tribeca and
Sundance and they're great and everybody
goes yeah and no one buys them no one
sees them and also think that's an
absolute movie star performance by that
man to my right mr. Frank Grillo ha
absolutely I think I think there's not
many guys who could do what he did in
this film and I think that's that's a
testament to again to him and you know
listen I'm now I find myself writing for
him even if I'm writing something he's
not supposed to be in myself so that's
the other thing it's like listen people
don't want to roll the dice and the
studio's don't want to take a shot and I
don't blame them but but it's a tough
business you know you look at this week
in this movie birds of prey which is has
all the elements and should been a big
hit it kind of wasn't you know kind of
it's it's what they consider failure and
that's a scary it's a scary thing for
studios when you have all the elements
that you know I've been in Marvel movies
and it's kind of a they know it's gonna
be successful they know they know and oh
boy do they know and that's probably the
only studio that knows because the rest
of it is is a gamble it's scary
unlike a movie that I wrote bad boys for
life which whatever was here we go
number one for three weeks in a row it's
not a big deal it's not a big no no no
it's okay you know it's the cloud no but
listen I didn't know that that was gonna
do that I had no idea I actually have
other questions for you guys and the
first thing is are you surprised because
bad boys for life came out of nowhere to
be as you said number one for three
weeks in a row
yeah I'm not no it's prank ghosts crazy
he said to me it's gonna make a lot of
money I don't know Will Smith but you
know it's crazy uh it patched up all of
our wayward relationships everybody
texts everybody did it you know so it
worked man and I'm and I'm thrilled and
and you never know but he he
told me it's gonna where I was like I
had no idea I've asked you guys this
question for at least 17 years and I'm
gonna ask it again you guys have the
rights to the raid or do you not have
the rights no we do we well well well
here's we have the rights to our version
are we sure we have we own the script
yeah the script that we wrote that we
have that your script is way cool it's
our script and we parted ways with X Y Z
who owns the title but not the script we
own the script and we are right now
negotiating with it's pretty sexy right
yeah with a big name we have another
name that we love that's gonna play
who's gonna play the bad guy
and so we're assembling this movie to be
we're going to do a movie called Leo
from Toledo with another Mel Gibson
movie myself and there we go yeah Joe's
gonna direct and then hopefully our
movie which is not called the raid but
it's the same script will be after that
guys this is clarification the the
version that I wrote they don't ever
intend to actually go in they think that
they're gonna move this guy so their
whole operation is we're gonna hit this
guy in transit and it's not until he
realized oh they're digging in they're
not they're not moving we've got an
outgoing again for those who know the
ring for those those that know the rate
it's a very very different script yeah
the bones of it the bones there's a
similar story inside of it but but but
it's really really really about the
brothers it's about the tubes not it's
not it's me and Brad Pitt anyway I'm
obsessed now with Brad Pitt I don't know
but Frank goes blonde which is really
really something to see I'll go blonde
for Brad Pitt do you guys have a new
title for this script it's called Brad
Pitt Brad Pitt it's actually Brad Pitt's
rade
that's that's we're reading Brad Pitt
is Brad here I love you I actually do
love practice just does it have a title
are you figuring it out xeno that's
what's called which is the character's
name called Xena so you know that's
that's that's the main characters z en
oh I don't can't spell it so you can't
know you really sold Z no listen no
that's what's called ribbon drinking I
do Am I you'll be both out I'm joking
no spelling in me or not the good
friends so you're getting ready to do
Leo from Toledo yeah so when he filming
this in about filming in about 11 weeks
yeah Mel plays a guy who is suffering
from a kind of waking dementia which is
he blacks out but he's he's conscious
he's awake and then he just lose time so
it's written in the script that he just
loses time which is kind of great if
your screen right go I don't know I'd
get past this [ __ ] oh he'll just
black out
and he basically is living as this guy
named leo ward and he has a encounter
with these kind of local let's call them
local toughs
and he wakes up in the hospital and his
friend who's a sheriff is staring at him
and he's handcuffed and he rolls his the
admittance bracelet over and he's it
says Conrad Varrick and Conrad Varrick
was his name when he was a hit man for
the Kansas City mob and he's in witness
protection now and he's just giving up
the ghost so they know he's alive
they're coming for him it's Mel Gibson
is like Martin Riggs in his 60s well me
and Fred Frank playing a Anderson Cooper
like hitman to come and get him yes and
by the way I'm saying that so Frank
commits to looking like an Anderson
Cooper like hitman it's on right there
bro no filming no I want to look at that
gives me [ __ ] I'm gonna go remember no
no we were out the screening and I said
he's handsome I like Anderson Cooper
almost as much as breath silver hair so
you got where you guys filming this is
anyway from Ohio
Scott where we filming this Ohio
Louisiana mile is it and you have more
than 27 days
no 26 do you have any days guiding Scott
35 30 yeah but it's much dirty dude so
it's not as much action so getting back
so the plan would be Leo God willing
Zenith II know with an X right and know
we'll talk and know so but you guys also
were producing other stuff and you have
other what else is coming up for you
guys in terms of war party uh we have a
script called graves that we're very
excited about which is basically Serpico
and poltergeist where the cop car is the
haunted house are just kind of cool yeah
this ain't called pound for pound which
is kind of an MMA rocky type thing
thorne which we're gonna I can't tell
you who's attached to a very favorite
woman but of he split up but it's but
it's um I wrote that I'm pretty excited
about that we're gonna do listen you
know and we're just trying to slowly
kind of plot forward and do our stupid
little [ __ ] and we're not really in the
we're not really in the you know over
twenty million dollar just not although
they're trying to drag us into that yeah
or just our mission statement was not to
make movies over twenty million bucks
and and when you go and sit down with
the studios which Joe and I often have
to go and sit with studio heads or you
know the streaming companies and well
you know and you were like well you know
we look we have this thing for 15
million bucks to me what do you have for
35 million yeah like I mean we just
sergeant company Frank say they want to
make movies between 30 and 80 million
bucks my why you know why I don't know
they don't want to pay us but they don't
make the movies you know Brad Pitt they
want to give him 20 I would pay Friday
if I'm not mistaken there was talk about
doing another thing of wheelman
wheelman yeah wheelman was our first
movie together that we as a company
right we made it for 5 million bucks
and we did an early screening of that at
our Clyde Sherman Oaks yes very very
thankful we have that's a good little
movie that's a movie there's a testament
to 19 days and Joe nurtured this young
writer not so young actually and and
gave him notes and after a month this
script he gave me the script I'm like
this is amazing we can do this for 5
million bucks we gave it to CAA they
took at the can the next day to sell it
internationally to raise the money and
Netflix swooped in and bought the script
and they made this kid who directed the
movie
Jeremy rush he got signed by CAA and now
he gets movie offers that from the
studio's from that movie because no
never give up well yep I could be wrong
about this but I thought there was talk
about doing like another real man or am
I wrong about this no we we want you
know we wanted to but it's Jeremy we
can't get him off his but yeah guys if
you know Jeremy rush hopefully I'm gonna
stay right in the camera saying this
because it's gonna be a quieter Jeremy
come on and make will mention do
wheelman - yeah no you know he's
listened he's a very but he was a PA you
guys know what the kind of PA is right
production says and he was basically you
know shepherding actors from their
trailers to the set and he's been
writing this script for like years and
he sent it sent he was friends with
Chris Pine and Joe's friends with Chris
Pine and sent him the script on a cold
call and Joe read it and gave him notes
and that happened for like a month and
we went and made his movie within two
months this was a guy knocking on
actor's doors and now he is a director
at CAA you made a great movie and by the
way that when I look at that film I go
that's that's Jeremy's movie we I'm very
proud of it listen I would do that all
day every day if I could just make
movies like that I would do it all day
every day
that's what I want to do I you know blue
so guys if you got a script Frank's
gonna tape send it to me and on his way
on your way out
yeah be like the rest of my family to be
like this to my family in New York who
somehow became screaming artists all of
them I got an idea
yeah I actually want to do one more
question on boss level which is when I
talk about you actually working with
your son who I think is still here I
think he might have sped time yeah I was
gonna be like it's Brio left yeah so my
my thing though is what is it like
working with your son and you know what
is it like directing his son you know
there has to be a little bit of a
different dynamic
elissa man I listen he tried to sabotage
me he didn't want Ryo to do the movie so
he like I found out late he was like
frankly I gotta tell you I told Jeremy
Ali don't we can't he can't be in the
movie because I looked at because by the
way I'd known Rios is he's a baby by the
way he looks like an angel right he
looks like his mother and his father put
together which are both beautiful people
so he's this angel and he's got this
great little raspy voice and I knew and
by the way franca still a story when
when they were like Frank's like at some
point this little [ __ ] turn upstage
he was he was [ __ ] I swear to god he
was upstaging me and I'd be every minute
I'd be like you okay buddy he's like dad
dad I'm concentrating stop asking me if
I'm okay like all right you little [ __ ]
I'm just trying to help ya like take it
easy and Joe would throw him lines like
you know wild lines and I go okay so but
what he goes dad I'm talking to the
director and then we'd be like in the
scenes where we were walking and talking
and we'll be walking and talking he'd be
like moving ahead of me so the camera
would be on him and I'm like hey dude
move the [ __ ] back like move back here
like upstaging music well dad you gotta
walk faster and he said walk faster and
and all he wanted to know is when he was
going to be on INTP and that he wants to
know if if I could introduce him and I'm
not joking just even see yeah I hate
that kid
but also think it's like listen I knew
there's a certain kind of free for the
audience to buy into the film the
chemistry that a father's gonna have
with his son and and I have listened
somewhere
my son Rockne and my daughter Miley who
I love very dearly there they are and a
lot of this is I wrote this for those
guys I wrote this for my kids you know
it's like it's my it's my pain to you
know thinking I was there maybe not
being there maybe whatever but like that
connection is is so important and I
didn't want I wanted to avoid him like
pairing him with like you know
precocious pain-in-the-ass child actor
who's you know who can hit these cues
but it doesn't feel real and I knew that
him and Rio together they're being
undeniable kind of chemistry and it
works man you could see it it just it
absolutely works it's like he's talking
to his boy and there's some there's an
indelible thing that happens there's a
there's a remarkable thing that happens
there's an undeniable thing that happens
when you're talking about when you're
looking at something that you created
it's the thing is when I'm looking at
him as as the character I'm discovering
my son because I don't know my son so
I'm getting to discover him so all of
that that beautiful discovery for me is
watching my son act in real life and I'd
be watching him like his son of a [ __ ]
it's taking me 45 years to get a job
this [ __ ] kid he just
I mean he's fine he's 9 years old how
did he do it I'm discovering him and
falling and so it was really it was
really an interesting he was right I
mean he was 100% right again it kills me
I don't know where's Brad Pitt what was
the last big fight you two had yeah you
don't know you know you know I had one
by the way the one the one disagreement
he I said when we're doing the tooth
pulling scene cuz I think we were both
so stressed out and we went outside and
I said nothing we're doing is working
nothing we're doing this scene is
working and I walked away and I never
said another thing the next take the
frame
did was in the movie that was so you
don't we don't fight yeah we don't we
don't fight we make fun of each other we
don't fight we can oh it's too there's
too much of a fight with everybody we
fight every else but not each other yeah
I think this might be my last question
for you Joe
do you miss Twitter why miss Twitter No
Jesus Joe is Twitter punished by the way
those who follow me on Twitter it's
weird that six months would pass and I
would I wouldn't give a single follower
by the way can I look her in the camera
Jack Dorsey you're a fascist little
[ __ ] and I hope you go down
there you go there yeah yeah Jack you
hear that they're clapping because
you're a scumbag
no I you know what it's better for me
man do the New York Times crossword
puzzle and read CNN and yeah stay off of
that [ __ ] yeah Frank's on Instagram
he's got a lot of followers so III can't
even I'm not even on insta because I
mean I can't log into my account that's
what a [ __ ] I am I can't even get on my
account good my kids don't help me they
don't give a [ __ ] they want me off they
want me just to be like in the Stone Age
right kids you've won you've won guys on
that note I'm gonna say a huge thank you
to arc light cinemas yes guys and guys
it means a lot that you guys came out
man I really thank you so much
tremendous fantastic and I hope you
enjoyed the film and if you didn't
please don't [ __ ] say that but if you
did enjoy it blow it up I really
appreciate it guys
yeah I was gonna say that if you enjoy
if you enjoyed the movie please talk
about it socially just don't write any
reviews Joe and Frank thank you so much
for showing you brother in for the Q&A
[Applause]